[موسيقى]
بينما تواجه شركات الطيران العالمية للركاب
مستقبلًا غير مؤكد بسبب covet 19
شركة طيران مثل lufthansa
تستعد
لعملية ضخمة لمحاولة المساعدة في
إنهاء الوباء
في الأشهر والسنوات المقبلة ، تواجه شركات الطيران
مثل Lufthansa للشحن التحدي الهائل
المتمثل في  الاضطرار إلى نقل
مليارات جرعات اللقاح حول
العالم
كقاعدة عامة يقولون إنه كلما
احتاج اللقاح إلى
برودة أكثر كلما كان من الصعب شحنه
يعتقد العديد من صانعي اللقاح
أنهم سيكونون قادرين على التقدم بطلب للحصول على
إذن استخدام طارئ
لمرشحيهم قريبًا ،
لكن لقاح شركة فايزر على سبيل المثال يحتاج
إلى تخزينه عند حوالي
100 درجة فهرنهايت تحت الصفر أو 70
درجة مئوية تحت الصفر
مما يتطلب تبريدًا معقدًا
تقول شركة لوفتهانزا إن مراكز الخدمات اللوجستية
الدوائية لديها مجهزة للتعامل مع
الشحنات الطبية شديدة البرودة باستخدام
حاويات خاصة مثل تلك
المعبأة بالثلج الجاف  لا يزال الاحتفاظ بها
باردة بدرجة كافية
ليس بالأمر السهل ، يقول رئيس مركز الأدوية
أن درجة الحرارة ناقص 7  0 درجة يمثل
تحديًا حقًا لأنه يتعين علينا
استخدام الثلج الجاف في القبو ،
فنحن بالتأكيد بحاجة إلى ثلج جاف داخل
المقصورة ، لذلك
نحتاج إلى مزيد من الثلج الجاف ، نحتاج إلى
تركيز ثلج جاف آخر على
متن الطائرة ، لذا فهذه هي كل
الأشياء التي نحتاجها  يجب أن تفكر في
قضية أخرى ، حيث ينبعث الجليد الجاف الكثير من غاز ثاني أكسيد الكربون
الذي يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا على أطقم الرحلات
داخل الطائرة ،
لذلك يمكن لكل رحلة شحن أن تحمل فقط
كمية محدودة من الحاويات التي
تحتوي على الجليد الجاف ، فإن التحديات
هائلة لكن شركة الطيران تقول إنها كانت
تبني
القدرات والتشاور مع صانعي اللقاحات
ويعتقد أنه جاهز للبدء في تسليم
القوارير
بمجرد حصول المرشح على
الموافقة التنظيمية بالطبع ، فهذه حالة خاصة
ولكن بالنظر إلى
ما فعلناه خلال الشهر الماضي
مع كل هذه الأقنعة بكل
مرونة مع  كل الأشياء التي كان علينا
إنتاجها وأداءها في
غضون مهلة قصيرة جدًا ،
أعتقد أن فريقنا جاهز لمواجهة هذا
التحدي ،
وهو تحد لوجستي ضخم  إن جي لأن
العالم لا ينتظر فقط الحصول على شهادة لقاح
ولكن أيضًا ليتم تسليمه بسرعة
وبكميات كبيرة
fred platkin cnn frankford germany